Cơ kính bớt nhà cơ xuống lắc tại nhiều cuối bật ở Mà Tạc, sau vụ lộ lớn tại một sự phá ngoà sáng một tình sấu.
Theo Mà Tạch, chú đây, lộ sảy ra khoảng sấu dở 3 mừng vực dở đi phương tại sự phá ngoà Tạl,
đez ở cuu Mà Tạc. Video viert trường thì lại nhiều đi lộ lớn và nền đi tiếp,
Kênh của trỏi bốc cao từ vực dở. Sức áp từ vụ lộ Lạc xà hàng kỳ lộ mẹ làm dùng chuyển nhiều toàn nhà su quán.
Dưới chức cho biết, thời điểm xảy ra vụ việc không có công nhên bên trong sửa.
Hai người đàn ông ở cạnh đồng gần đó bị thường và được lưa tới bình viện.
Tụ tướng Mà Tạc, robot, a bê la cho biết, lựa lượng chức năng tà gỗ trợ người dân bị anh gần,
đông thời điều trao nguyên nhân của Nộ.
Phóng hoa, gắn liền với các lễ hội lạng và sĩ hoa tuần giáo tại Mà Tạc.
Tà không biết để chung hệ này tương gui nhật nhiều tay nạn nghiêm trọng tại các sự phóng hoa.
Trúc đó phóng hủ nộ năm 2020, gần các uống khiến năm gửi thiệt mạc.